Sounds like the system is getting better there.
Now, my understanding is this rat's
nest of computers is also gone.
Right. So in the process of
moving to Cassandra,
the system for the precomputed queries became
--a lot more of them were mutated in place.
What the app will do when say, you remove
something from your saved links
it has to be taken out of your saved page.
Is it will fetch from Cassandra the
precomputed list of your saved page,
remove the item from it that you didn't want anymore,
and then put it back into Cassandra,
and it has to lock around that.
But the advantage there is it doesn't
have to just re-run the entire query
because it will only making one little change.
So, instead of sending this
complex query to a machine
that's already doing a lots of complex queries,
You just smartly update the--. >>Right. >>
The ultimate product of this is a cache.
Yes. >>So you just update the cache directly?
Right. There are a few types of queries
that that's not possible with
and those are things like your top links of this hour.
So this all goes away? >>Yes.
Yes. I'm just going to make this go away.
We do still use "Q." >>We still have a "Q".
>>But not for this stuff. >>Okay.
The top links of this hour that kind of stuff instead
is recomputed enmasse for the
entire site using MapReduce,
and what that does is it will dump every link
that was submitted in the last hour
and it like groups them up and
figures out where they should go
and them just completely overwrites
those listings every 10-15 minutes.
We haven't talked about MapReduce yet.
The first question I have for you is the data that you're mapping over, where is that stored?
It's coming out of Postgres.
So you have a job that takes that out of Postgres
and then runs the big job on it? >>Right.
Now, is this the same set of machines
that you would use for--
We have one slave for links dedicated.
Okay. So, there's like another little replica
that is only read for dumps.
Yeah. >>Now, what about the comments
and votes in these other guys?
There is no actual queries that need that.
>>Ah. Good point, good point.
There is this special links thing and then
you run MapReduce jobs on this
ever so often and than that
get stored in Cassandra.